[Musique]
près de 39 millions de voitures
circulent sur les routes françaises
potentiellement il y à 39 millions
d'avis à propos du passage de 90 à 80
km/heure sur certains axes secondaires
plus de sécurité routière pour certains
volonté de remplir les caisses de l'état
pour d'autres bonsoir à tous la
réduction de la vitesse à 80 km/heure et
en débat ce soit près de 600 kilomètres
de routes du département des yvelines
sont concernés par la mesure qui sera
effective à partir du dimanche 1er
juillet précisément ce sont elles et
route à double sens en séparateur
central en dehors des deux fois deux
voies et des route à trois voies mais
alors cet abaissement ou sera-t-il
vraiment efficaces comme le promet le
gouvernement pourquoi tant de polémiques
et de débats pour 10 km heure ça paraît
peu dans les zones urbaines mais le
symbole est fort pour les zones rurales
pour discuter et débattre quatre invités
sur notre plateau ce soir jean-yves
petit directeur yvelines de
l'association prévention routière bruno
myle yens député modem des yvelines
membres aussi de la commission du
développement durable et de
l'aménagement du territoire à
l'assemblée nationale daniel quéro
président de l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes et philippe geste lent
président des maires ruraux des yvelines
et maire aussi de méricourt village des
yvelines
bonsoir à tous les 4 mois soit bruno
myle yens je me tourne instinctivement
vers vous vous êtes membre de la
majorité à l'assemblée nationale cette
mesure on en parle depuis depuis le mois
de janvier concrètement depuis depuis
l'annnonce du du premier ministre edward
edouard philippe
et ce depuis tout ce temps vous devez
avoir les oreilles qui sifflent un petit
peu sur le terrain est ce que ça s'est
amplifié depuis depuis la proche de de
l'entrée en vigueur de cette mesure qui
sera dimanche
est-ce qu'on vous en parle beaucoup sur
le terrain dire que la mesure est
populaire là je vous mentirais ça c'est
clair
elle est assez impopulaire
après moi j'ai pas d'avis tranché sur la
question au départ je dis simplement que
si c'est effectivement puisque c'est un
test sur deux ans si c'est un test à une
expérimentation et si ça peut sauver des
vies
tentons le si ça ne marche pas moi je
serai le premier à réclamer le retour à
90 km/heure en revanche si ça marche le
gouvernement aurait eu raison
aujourd'hui le gouvernement table sur
300 à 400 vies qui pourraient être
épargnés par an daniel je vais vous
donner un exemple que j'ai entendu ce
matin sur une radio périphérique
il me semble que c'est dans le
département de l'yonne mais je suis pas
sûr à 100% du département ils ont sur
l'expérimentation sur une route
particulièrement dangereuse pendant deux
ans on est passé de six morts
un mort on est passé de 16 accident très
grave à six accidents très graves
voilà ce que je pose ça pourrait marcher
ayrault votre avis sur cette mesure et
puis sur ces chiffres un kiss on va dire
beaucoup
mise en avant par le par le gouvernement
300 à 400 me qui prépare comme 76% des
français et 81% des usagers de la route
nous sommes contre cette mesure
pourquoi parce que les français ne la
comprennent pas et pourquoi ils la
comprennent pas parce qu' aucun exemple
les pays qui nous entourent où on a 400
mille kilomètres de routes nationales et
départementales à 80 et même un million
de route 1 puisque si on prend toutes
les routes secondaires sa famille on
doute qu'on mettrait à 80 donc ça il ya
personne qui personne qui a expérimenté
cela encore ensuite on a mis en place
des expérimentations qui n'ont jamais
démontré les chiffres et qu'on annonce
nous on a été voir des chanceux basse le
gouvernement se base sur des experts
internationaux qui donnerait c'est la
formule de neilson pour le d'ailleurs il
ya guère les français qui sont qui sont
intéressants nous on a été voir ce qui
se passe au danemark danemark le travail
sortait le passage de 80-90 pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont vu que sur leur route
naples épartement talent et nationales
quand vous avez une belle ligne droite
vous avez la moitié des gens qui roulent
au dessus c'est le danemark ont dit que
les français respectent rien au danemark
la vitesse moyenne est de 89 sur les
routes à 80 et les autres qui roulent en
dessous et au milieu vous savez des
camions qui double ce qui fait qu'il ya
plus d'accidents donc sur les tests
qu'ils ont mis en place il ya 12 %
demeurant - pouvez consulter vous allez
voir sur les sites de sécurité routière
au danemark
c'est véridique vous n'êtes pas
convaincus a pris aussi l'argument
habituel
chaque mesure qui concerne la sécurité
routière à chaque fois à les dénoncer à
les pointer du doigt et puis on se rend
compte quelques années plus tard que
finalement tourné avec les seuls à
mettre ça en place vous regardez les
pays qui nous entourent vous avez
l'angleterre roulent à 97 sur les routes
autoroutes et les allemands à chant et
jean meilleurs résultats en terme de
sécurité routière
est ce que nous on serait incapable de
sécuriser une route à des vitesses
accepté et acceptable c'est ça que les
gens comprennent pas philippe geste lent
et aussi il ya aussi le débat qui
s'installe sur ce sujet entre le monde
rural parfois et le monde urbain les
urbains comprendraient pas les
problématiques des ruraux qui ont moins
de transport qui doivent utiliser
beaucoup plus la voiture vous en qualité
de président des maires ruraux des
yvelines qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que
vous entendez sur le terrain quel est
votre point de vue bien évidemment on
est tous d'accord pour faire tout ce
qu'il faut pour faire diminuer le nombre
d'accidents dans notre pays on est
conscient aussi que l'état n'arriveront
pas à résorber son déficit
il a envie de se remplumer ce qui nous
gêne nous c'est qu'on voudrait pas être
les dindons de la farce est qui qui
prennent des plumes sont pour vous pour
vos l'objectif c'est ça c'est de faire
plus de flash éventuellement plus de
demandes
nous ce qu'on dit c'est que il ya
peut-être des endroits où il fallait
aller encore plus loin que les 80
kilomètres c'est peut-être justifiée
dont celle d'autres gens possible de le
faire mais elle vous le préfet de
département peuvent le dire que
peut-être que potentiellement on
pourrait passer dans quelques temps de
80 70 certaines ont augmenté mais le
préfet avec le conseil départemental a
les moyens de baisser au cours la
vitesse on sait que dans certains
emballages et c
voilà c'est possible c'est même
souhaitable quitte parfois à créer un
peu de la confusion quand on passe de 70
80 90 revenir à 80 où vous seriez vous
éventuellement favorable à faire cas par
cas comme ça très précisément alors ça
c'est un ça c'est un autre problème
parce que surveiller son compteur comme
on est obligé de le faire maintenant
pour rester dans les clous on y arrive
facilement quand on est sur l'autoroute
quand on est sur nos routes de campagne
c'est juste pas possible moi j'avoue que
j'ai trois écrans sur la voiture et il
ça m'arrive encore des taux dessus ou
des fois carrément en dessous mais voilà
il suffit d'une seconde d'inattention
alors que vous êtes bien comportés toute
la journée et claquent les jumelles ou
radar qu'on n'a pas vue n'aura
l'occasion justement entendre un
gendarme sur ce sujet qui dirait que la
priorité c'est de la prévention dans un
premier temps jean yves petit pour
l'association prévention routière
quelle est votre position à vous sur le
sujet est ce que la vitesse finalement
c'est le premier levier pour réduction
pour réduire le nombre de morts sur les
routes françaises
je sais pas si c'est le premier levier
mais en tout cas c'est la première cause
d'accidents mortels sur nos routes
la vitesse cette mesure a du sens la
réduire la vitesse a du sens il est
évident enfin c'est une évidence pour
tout le monde que moins on va vite
- les accidents sont graves et donc
moins les moyens à tuer moyen de blessés
ça paraît une énième quiero n'a pas
l'air d'accord avec ça ça m'a rien fait
c'est sûr c'est absolument partir du
moment où une voiture roule c'est sûr
qu'ils richetin l'accident bien ce que
je disais tout à l'heure pour les
niveaux n'y a qu'un pas non c'est
corrigé de route comme nos voyages à des
vitesses accepté au congrès on mettre en
place encore le seul modèle vaduz se
jeter sur les ch'tis j'ai choisi
j'ai pas dit le contraire au contraire
j'abonde dans votre sens puisque j'avais
préparé mais aussi un petit
quelques notes sur les pays étrangers
egea j'arrive exactement aux mêmes
conclusions vous bien sûr si ce n'est
que nous ne sommes pas les premiers à le
faire puisqu'il ya déjà un certain
nombre de petits pays qui l'ont fait en
superficie 1
nous sommes nous avons le réseau lance
donc donc nous sommes effectivement le
premier grand pays en superficie à
expérimenter même par expérimenté avoir
décidé cette mesure
bon c'est une mesure impopulaire
courageuse faut quand même le
reconnaître au gouvernement nous verrons
bien ce que ça fait il y avait
certainement d'autres moyens de réduire
la vitesse ça a été évoqué déjà comment
laissée aux préfets par exemple le
le soit selon les mains le choix va pas
seulement département mais selon selon
les zones
selon les zones à risque et ne pas
forcément ajouter une limitation à 80
km/heure mais l'essai à 90 la hausse est
justifiée et réduire à 70 là où ça l'est
aussi puisque vous avez évoqué la
multiplicité des panneaux et des
différents même en ville parfois des
patients à 47 bien sûr c'est déjà le cas
et mais on n'est parfait introduites du
renault milliers de la loi il ya deux
choses qu'il faut bien voir c'est le
sait l'état qui qui fait le code de la
route et à partir du moment où le code
de la route a été décidé effectivement
les préfets et des présidents de
départements ont le choix de faire autre
chose par augmenter mais peuvent décès
selon les études accidentogènes de leur
département
ça c'est une chose donc pourquoi 80 km
est pourquoi partout parce que si on
avait laissé la possibilité aux élus de
faire comme ils voulaient et c'est
normal et je pense que j'aurais été élu
à leur place j'aurais fait exactement la
même chose on aurait pu se retrouver
avec deux typologies accidentogène
exactement identique à divise ds
différentes d'accord selon le
département et ça quelque part ce
jusqu'en phase dépressive et bien de
penser un petit peu à simplifier
peut-être bah si c'est simple on peut
prendre de route quasi identique
d'accord dont une sur un département
aurait été à 80 km/heure et l'autre on
l'aurait laissée à 90 donc ça c'est ses
oreilles ça aurait quand même pour les
automobilistes or là pour le coup ça
aurait été encore plus compliqué à
comprendre c'est à dire que en passant
d'un département à un autre on aurait pu
se retrouver avec des limitations dit
est complètement différente pour des
pour des routes exactement de même
typologie accidentogène donc voilà après
vous pouvez effectivement rebaisser à
60,10 vous prépare montrer 90 sauf au
terme de l'expérience du gouvernement a
annoncé qu'il pourrait faire marche
arrière vous pensez pas vous n'y croyez
pas j'étais un support de conseillers de
monsieur le premier ministre juste avant
le cifr et j'avais on après je racontais
j'aimerais demander les résultats de
l'expérimentation il ya eu lieu en
france qui a été lancé par mais ce
qu'attendent les gens pas voulu nous les
donner s'ils savaient vraiment marché on
nous les aurait sorti nous on a été les
chercher on a été les voir on a des
des statistiques et finalement si vous
regardez dans la haute-saône les
chiffres étaient plus mauvais qu'avant
pourquoi parce que sur une route à 80
quand vous avez une belle ligne droite
les gens double c'est sous les lignes
droites à 80 et vous sachant qu'elles
trouveront les muscles des canadiens qui
l'avait pas laissé les camions sont
limitées à 80 il ya des gens qui vont
dire assez mais non justement il y aura
plus il ya des gens à voter presque
puisque quand vous êtes d'accord mais
quand la vraie vie il faut regarder ce
qui est dans la vraie vie ce n'est pas
la vie en ville je suis d'accord avec
vous dans la mesure où moi-même je
maîtrise des philippes tout à l'heure je
respecte pas tout le temps la limite à
grande vitesse je suis bien d'accord je
termine la démonstration qu'on a vu
c'est la démonstration qu'on a vu sur le
terrain c'est que vous avez des gens qui
vont au dessus de 80 des gens qui ont
peur de se faire prendre
roulant sous et au milieu les camions
qui double il ya des camions qui sont
sortis dans la haute-saône dans les
champs vous allez voir les gens qui sont
autour de ces deux rues de là ils vont
leur expliquer donc la vraie vie c'est
ça c'est pas des formules mathématiques
coppola sécurité routière philippe geste
lent pour rebondir sur l'analyse que
font les automobiles je crois qu'ils
réfléchissent plus maintenant les
automobilistes ils font ce qu'on leur
demande ils subissent les panneaux il
essaye même plus de se poser la question
si c'est bien que c'est pas bien et
c'est de respecter
je suis d'accord avec vous sur
l'histoire des captures parce que c'est
vrai que limité à 80 comme nous et par
moments ils votent à 77 et qui
d'ailleurs une petite pente et donc le
gars qui va se trouver coincé derrière
un camion ça va durer ça va durer des
heures il pourra pas doublé we know me
gêne aussi c'est cet argument qu'on a
entendu au début de l'émission sur le
fait qu' on a l'impression que le
gouvernement va chercher de l'argent
dans les gens qui se dépassent tous les
jours vous devez longtemps dit magyd
jouer mais ça on verra un mois je vous
rappelle quand même que sur les yvelines
ces deux radars en plus ces deux radars
programmer les informations qui vont
peut-être s'afficher c'est si vous avez
entendu quand même lire les infos
nécessaires les radars mobiles mobile
non identifiés sur les routes et là on
vous annonce préventis privatisant ces
radars on va passer de 2 millions de
flash à 12 millions de francs
la limitation de vitesse aujourd'hui
vous pouvez constater que sur les 90 km
heure qui sont sur nos routes je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens sur certaines
portions jeu le salaire et une tension
qui ne respectent pas cette image passée
de biovision à s'allonger 9 la chercher
la réalité oui mais ça n'a rien à voir
mais qu'est-ce que soit la vitesse que
vous mettez de toute façon si vous
augmentez le nombre de radars vous aurez
ville privatiser sur cheyrou delà donc
finalement on aurait passé on est on est
à plus de 10m à des mesures ciblées de
10 millions d'amis automatique et en
plus l'enva patients pour 400 millions
de plus et puis ça fait partie d'une
ligne budgétaire c'est quand même pas
normal quand les gens disent on a
l'impression que pour le portefeuille
on peut pas leur donner tort aux gens
ils petit wilrijk tout à l'heure je
n'étais pas allée jusqu'au bout
allez-y je crois que je n'ai pas dit je
voulais quand même dire pour vous
soutenir que l'association prévention
routière soutient la mesure
nous regrettons seulement comme ça déjà
été évoqué que cette expérimentation a
été menée que sur deux ans et sur 80
kilomètres ça va suture beaucoup les
deux ans alors attendez je termine
baisser les cours pour ce genre
d'expérimentations comme ça il aurait
fallu que ça soit sur cinq ans par
exemple
là on aurait pu avoir des résultats
significatifs sur deux ans c'est pas
significative nous avait dit qu'il ya un
département où il ya eu un accident un
autre viendra plus donc c'est pas
significatif il aurait fallu que ce soit
plus long maintenant alors l'association
prévention routière n'a à mon sens n'a
pas demandé d'avis là-dessus mais je
pense personnellement que dans deux ans
ça restera comme ça
les chiffres ne vont pas évoluer le à
quelque chose c'est pas suffisant il
faut continuer ce qu'on m'a répondu moi
donc voilà on se reverra peut-être dans
deux ans je voudrais juste qu'on est
chez bruno millions juste on écoute
justement un gendarme responsable de la
sécurité routière dans les yvelines
il annonce que pendant dans un premier
temps il y aura surtout de la prévention
et pas forcément de pénalisation on va
écouter ce que nous allons faire c'est
accompagner le changement de cette
nombre et je vais demander aux gendarmes
dieu sait que tant routière des yvelines
de faire preuve de pédagogie pour
expliquer les raisons de ce changement
le 1er juillet les jours qui suivront
nous serons sur les routes a réalisé des
contrôles routiers
mais le seront prioritairement axé sur
le contrôle des grands excès de vitesse
les plus dangereux c'est bien ça notre
mission et pas sur les excès de vitesse
qui sont les moins importants je me
tourne vers vous deux messieurs vous
êtes convaincus par par ses propos
pédagogie avant tout vu
on l'espère bien mais bon moi c'est pas
rares voix sur l'avenue entre rognés
mantes-la-jolie de voir le gendarme avec
ses 2 le policier avec ses jumelles qui
est juste après le panneau et par où
passe de 90 à 50 sur l'entrée de dakar
ou comment j'ai fait pour améliorer la
sécurité routière selon vous si c'est
pas par la vitesse comme on améliorera
la sécurité routière dessous le problème
c'est qu'en france on a l'impression
qu'il ya une cause à la mortalité
routière la vitesse et qu'une solution
orale a alors qu'il ya de multiples
causes et puis si vous regardez la
vitesse selon bien sonnés on parle de la
vitesse l'alcool et après suivant les
chiffres à peu près autant oui mais là
où l'accord est jugé l'appareil visé moi
mais quand vous êtes alcoolisées plus
vous allez mettre plus vous allez avoir
un salaire de casques de réserve à
l'angleterre l'angleterre - 2000 mans
parents y roulent à 97 sur les routes
secondaires mais par contre ils ont
divisé par deux le nombre d'alcoolémie
au volant
donc c'est possible prévention éducation
sur le long terme
ils ont réussi à le faire vous avez le
téléphone vous avez la chaux violence
vous avez les routes ou 2000 et
d'émotion on agit aussi là dessus
oui parce qu'il n'est pas ce que parce
que le plan de prévention routière ces
18 mesure ça ne s'arrête pas le blague
la nation à 80 chèques mais il est temps
que ces mesures ne parle que du char va
l'essayer oui mais parce que les
insurgés n'ont jamais roger en plus
impopulaire pour nous sur les 17 mesures
j'allais justement par l'épreuve
il y avait marqué 17 autres mesures
surlignés en jaune il ya notamment
ça va être rendre obligatoire la pose
d'un éthylotest antidémarrage pour
l'élevage sidi liste j'étais encore la
possibilité pour les forces de l'ordre
de retenir le permis conduire d'une
personne sanctionné pour conduite avec
usage de téléphone tenu en main ou
encore améliorer la prise en charge des
victimes d'accidents augmenté de la
route on va augmenter les contrôles sur
les stupéfiants on va augmenter les
contrôles sur l'alcoolémie
mais oui les stupéfiants maintenant on a
les moyens
pour les on les avait pas il ya patients
dont parle pas très juste fait un petit
point moi je pense que en plus sur
l'énervement autour des 80 km heure il
ya quand même une chose qui s'est passé
dans l'histoire de la prévention
routière des dernières années c'est que
depuis le plan prévention routière de
jacques chirac en 2002 qui a vu comme
avec les radars et c'est la mortalité de
50 % même plus d'ailleurs il ya on a eu
un quinquennat complet sans aucune sans
aucune mesure ne serait ce que de
prévention ne serait-ce que d'en parler
pendant cinq ans au gouvernement
hollande personne n'a parlé de
prévention routière donc on arrive on
reparle de ça et on réalimente les
polémiques j'en ai vu son utilité n'est
là les radars à l'époque on a supprimé
les grands excès de vitesse mais faut
bien reconnaître que depuis 2001 la
mortalité a vachement oui mais regardez
de l'étude ils vont me regarder
regardez tous à ghislain d'europe
regardez tous les chiffres en europe les
courbes alors radars ou partielle peu
près la même j'ai des chiques mois sur
ce cas qu'en allemagne l'état sion
explique avec malice portion d'autoroute
qui sont encore sans limitation de
vitesse les allemands dans leur grande
majorité demandent à ce qu'on mette une
limite et les gens parce qu'ils varient
la vitesse en fonction des conditions de
roulage
on va donner les clés de compréhension
aux téléspectateurs un accident en moyen
dans l'union européenne ces quarante
neuf décès par million d'habitants ses
53 en france décès par million
d'habitants donc c'est un peu au dessus
de la moyenne européenne l'allemagne ses
38 la grande bretagne ces 27 l'espagne
c'est 40 et l'italie se trouve un peu au
dessus de nous au dessus de nous 56 mort
dpic
c'est quoi la priorité aujourd'hui si
c'est pas la vitesse selon vous jean
yves petit est ce que c'est
dès le plus jeune âge par exemple des
plantations des plongeurs il y a il nous
reste peu de temps je sais pas s'il peut
y avoir une priorité mais il ya trois
axes dans lesquels il faut agir
sur l'homme c'est à dire l'éducation dès
le plus jeune âge le permis de conduire
la sensibilisation la prévention et la
répression faut pas l'oublier
boursière et éventuellement les mais
pourquoi pas bien sûr vous parlez de
l'alcool en angleterre ils sont beaucoup
plus sévères que l'on en angleterre sur
des affaires d'alcool
oui donc donc donc premièrement l'homme
deuxièmement la voirie la voirie doit
largement enfin peut être amélioré aussi
bien sûr exactement
et troisièmement le véhicule et ça il ya
des progrès énormes
en ce moment les voitures automatiques
et donc c'est dans ces trois axes là
qu'il faut agir et je sais pas s'il ya
une vraie de vérité là-dedans pas c'est
une question de sous évidemment bruno
blier et philippe g cela par l'union
après justin justin point sur la voirie
oui la voirie doit être améliorée ça je
suis d'accord avec vous mais les routes
qui sont en mauvais état vous font
conduire plutôt moins vite que plus vite
virer tôt elza premiers points 2e point
sur les véhicules de dôme sur les
véhicules d'ici à 2040 il n'y a plus de
moteur thermique en 2015
ça s'arrête les véhicules électriques
amène à l'apaisement rouler moins vite
et vous verrez que demain on ne conduira
plus du tout comme aujourd'hui
alors je vais pas dire que c'est un
combat d'arrière-garde mais on pousse
partout pour que de toute façon la
vitesse réduite et que la fluidité sur
les routes se fasse à une vitesse à peu
près normale et moins dangereuse lors
des accidents
philippe geste lent vous qui est de
maire d'une petite commune quel est
l'état des routes dans votre ville aux
alentours
est ce que c'est ça aussi le procès ça
se dégrade les finances des
collectivités étant ce qu'elles sont on
va faire le débat mais ça se dégrade et
de plus en plus ça c'est un gros gros
souci est sur le point précédent
moi je suis tout à fait favorable à la
prévention et à l'éducation
et je pense qu'on doit faire ça à partir
du plus jeune âge on a un bon ministre
ni segment il faudrait qu'il se saisisse
du sujet et ça doit faire partie du
parcours scolaire
le gouvernement prévoit une formation
pour les vélos pour les piétons au
collège
nous avons parlé de formation prévention
et du cash ou qui en parle mais on est
dans l'ultra répression tout le temps
c'est très propre faudrait pas faire la
politique de sécurité routière contre
les automobilistes voilà faire un vrai
que les automobilistes
oui mais vous pouvez pas dire ça parce
que c'est vous qui avez monté le débat
sur les 80 km/heure et vous n'avez
jamais parler des autres pas du tout je
suis alors parole des automobilistes
jeudi ce que oui mais je trouve
important d oui mais parce que la
communication du gouvernement a
peut-être été même pas faire les
questions que j'allais vous pourrez pas
les politiques prennent trop de
questions non mais vous savez bien vous
vous aviez contre les 80 km de la faire
partir en 1972 avec la ceinture je ne la
fais moi je me souviens dans l'hémicycle
salvagnac doublé en dix ans le papa à la
voiture prend feu on mourra pas pareil
dans les flammes machin et sécher leur
apparition sauvera personnes là tout le
monde l'a essayé ça c'est des discours
malheureusement les politiques ont des
discours mais c'est par le moins
populiste si vous ne perdiez le dire et
laisser les publics pour monter légende
contre une mesure dont ils ne veulent
pas et qui le ramène quand même de
l'électorat
moi j'essaye d'être le plus honnête
possible mais si ça allait très bien je
bats politique moi je moi j'essaie
j'essaye d'être le plus honnête possible
en vous disant si ça peut sauver six
avaient pu sauver la femme enceinte de
huit mois et qui est morte à maul bien
sûr d'accord je suis dacc et tout le
monde est d'accord général d'accord pour
l'émotion après j'avais fait le polynôme
c'est parce qu'il sait pas la question
c'est arrivé après la chamade et je sais
pas ce que je veux dire je veux dire
simplement que si l'expérimentation est
bonne on continue et tant mieux si
l'exploitation est mauvaise je serai le
premier monsieur à vous rejoindre sur
les cadres ayant de philippe philippe
geste lent bref il ya un gros problème
de communication de la part du
gouvernement sur des sujets comme ça
nous on a le sentiment nous qui sommes
en bas on a ce sentiment que ça se
décide dans un bureau parisien et que ça
nous tombe dessus
je veux le dire uniquement uniquement
pour faire de la répression pour faire
du fric c'est comme ça que j'ai vécu et
nous les les automobilistes ruraux sur
les premiers à être touchés par ces
mesures parce que vous savez on n'a pas
de gars on a pas de transports en commun
donc nous l'automobile c'est
l'automobile est indispensable chez nous
donc ne serait bourget cherchez pas
suffit d'interroger des églises au jaune
il suffirait abroger les pompiers l'une
des plus graves cause d'accidents 55 %
de morts et comme ils sont sur ces
routes là et sont dus à la vitesse pour
terminer à temps vous discutez avec les
gendarmes et les policiers entre nous
quand on discute entre nous ils sont
sceptiques
daniel etter on va terminer sur une
dernière une dernière question 300 et
400 vies qui pourraient être épargnés
c'est le souhait du gouvernement
donc ça ferait trois mille morts par an
malheureusement sur les routes
françaises encore est ce que l'objectif
une question un peu naïve est ce que
l'objectif c'est zéro mort par an est ce
que c'est atteignable
j'arrive petit trait à l'heure
l'objectif qui a été fixé par l'union
européenne en 2010 c'était de diviser
par deux le nombre de tués sur les
routes d'ici 2020 ce qui pour la france
représente 2000 tués en 2020 c'est ça
l'objectif fixé par l'union européenne
ça sera atteignable selon vous il reste
deux ans chacun peut donc les mesures en
place on peut y arriver puisqu'il est
tout à l'heure par rapport à l'évolution
des véhicules électriques ou pas mais
vous regardez aujourd'hui certains
constructeurs comme volvo ou 10 en 2020
on va être capable de faire des voitures
sans accident dont il ya un progrès
aujourd'hui que les capteurs et c'est
donc un progrès énorme
donc on va arriver un moment où on va
quand même défendre encore on va faire
des progrès et dieu merci philippe
gestion vous aurez le mot de conclusion
de cette émission
le risque zéro ça n'existe pas donc
c'est sûr qu'une voiture qui roule pas
n'a pas d'accident
dans tous les cas on est tous d'accord
pour que prendre des mesures qui font
diminuer le nombre des victimes sont
nerveux forcément tous d'accord sur la
force énergie mais pas la meilleure
prévention c'est nous qui devons la
faire au volant de votre voiture
exactement puis et puis dans deux ans il
y aura donc une phase 2 et 4 merci à
vous quatre c'est la fin de ce site
suite le débat prochaine émission jeudi
prochain à 18h30 en direct
d'ici là vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission replay sur tv 78 points comme
ou l'application tv 78 et soyez prudents
aussi sur la route et fait attention
désormais aux panneaux 80 merci à tous
et bonne soirée
merci
[Musique]